devil facial tumour disease is a very
strange and bizarre new type of cancer
usually starts off as a small tumor a
little nodule on the lips or inside the
mouth or somewhere on the face however
this rapidly within the course of a few
weeks to months develops into a massive
ulcerating tumor as the tumors grow
especially when they are inside their
oral cavity inside the mouth the tumors
can remove dentition can displace bones
from the jaw so it's very hard for the
animal to feed and is hard to compete
for food is being scavengers with other
just many Devils but also because it's a
cancer is creating a lot of damage in
the internal organs so I think there's a
combination of factors that makes that
animal die within the year
you